bonjour c'est pour une telle excitation
oui vous avez quoi comme symptôme en
fait j'ai fait une analyse de sang et je
serais pour l'analyse et du coup
dacquois est un médecin
la borne de télémédecine est connu du
grand public seulement depuis quelques
semaines et elle est déjà victime de son
succès le centre communal d'action
sociale où elle est installée a même dû
instaurer une prise de rendez vous
et après m'être le casque ok super merci
avec les médecins qui sont en ce moment
en congé et donc voilà il ya beaucoup de
demandes pour des renouvellements
d'ordonnancés les symptômes qu'ovide
aussi on est doublée de demander des
rendez vous normalement c'est sans
rendez-vous période ne fait pas la
pénurie de médecins généralistes et elle
en centre val de loire que la
téléconsultation fait de plus en plus
d'adeptes je suis arrivé à bleau à cette
année et c'est vrai que j'ai pas pu se
trouver un nouveau médecin parce que les
médecins et prennent plus de nouveaux
patients donc ceux qui arrivent comme ça
récemment enfin peuvent pas trouver de
médecin traitant donc ils sont obligés
de faire avec les moyens qu'ils trouvent
donc là les bornes c'est parfait
depuis qu vie de le curseur a un peu
changé et la visio la télémédecine passé
quelque chose maintenant qui est en
train peu dans les moeurs votre première
cliente a été une personne une senior de
85 ans qui n'arrivait pas à obtenir de
rendez vous qui avez une pathologie elle
n'arrivait pas avoir deux d'ordonnancé
et elle est venue à la bande de
téléconsultation ça s'est parfaitement
bien passé à beaugency la borne de
télémédecine ne risque pas de désemplir
avant longtemps la ville a l'espoir de
recruter un médecin au courant de
l'année prochaine un médecin qui
n'exerceraient qu'à mi temps